when I was a child I always wanted to be
doing something other people are not
doing when I was five years old I wanted
to be an astronaut first grade I got my
first computer and I got extremely
addicted when I took a computer science
course in high school everything changed
I met with dr. Yvonne Pendleton when I
was in the fourth grade I'm still in
middle school I wanted to do a science
for her project
I found myself absolutely obsessed with
developing a non stop writing code and
trying to figure things out on my own so
I started learning HTML I just told her
up front I want to go to UC Berkeley and
I want to become an astrophysicist I
spent a lot of time talking with the
researchers and I learned about ending
aging she was very excited to see
somebody so young interested in
astrophysics I just felt that this is
what I want to do I wanted to stop
cancer
I like flowing to problems I really like
seeing people use my product do what I
want to focus on over the next two years
is how much could I learn now I had this
opportunity to change the world and
that's my passion today so that's what